[Musique]
c
la technologie du 21e siècle au service
d'oeuvres millénaire les manuscrits de
l'abbaye du mont saint michel dans cet
atelier éphémère installée dans la
bibliothèque patrimoniale d'avranches
tous sont numérisés page après page
c'est un travail très minutieux très
patient qui impose la même humilité que
les moines copistes
on l'a fait en leur temps la notion du
temps et quand même bien différente
pour réaliser cet ouvrage de 700 pages
il fallait des dizaines de jours aux
moines copistes en 2016
une seule journée pour le reproduire et
répertorier les clichés à la définition
optimale la résolution de la prise de
vue lors de cette campagne nous permet
d'aller au-delà de ce qu'on peut voir
simplement à l'oeil nu
ça nous permet d'avoir une lecture plus
précise à la fois des enluminures de la
technique de la peinture sur manuscrit
est aussi également de la technique de
l'année ce cri tout simplement cette
opération de numérisation lancé il y a
dix ans par la ville d'avranches et
l'université de caen s'achèvera à la fin
du mois l'objectif créer une
bibliothèque virtuelle sur internet les
199 manuscrits conservés à avranches
seront en libre accès là on va faire en
face de moi j'ai des manuscrits qui ont
quasiment milan et qui ont conservé
toutes leurs couleurs dont les textes
sont parfaitement lisibles par
l'intermédiaire de ce site internet
on aura l'impression qu'ils sont tous au
même endroit dans la bibliothèque 2005
michel l'utilisateur le lecteur le
chercheur aura au même endroit l'accès à
ces documents
la bibliothèque virtuelle du mont saint
michel sera opérationnel au cours de
l'année 2017 est hébergé sur le site de
l'université de caen
pour un savoir ancestral à la
disposition de tous et sur toute la
planète